[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today we got
Laura in Phoenix Arizona what's going on
Laura Laura are you there did I get
her are you there okay it was my nails I
blame my nails are you there hello okay
what's going on Laura Jade's Nails got
in the way
again what's up Laura yes so I need help
on So currently we're on
30,000 in debt so we always sit down and
talk about our debts um say like we sit
down on uh on the Monday everything goes
good and then the weekend start um we
have an issue where my husband likes to
drink um like
Friday sometimes Friday through Sunday
wow and then during that time he like he
forgets about our like budget well I
would think
so yeah so then that goes out the window
and then Monday comes and it's
like he's ready to start again yeah and
he's like what happened um we I thought
we had sat down and talked about our
budget how long's that's been going
on um I would say like six months we
we've tried to
get together and try to like pay off our
debt but it's just not working yeah
you're married to somebody who's really
struggling with
alcohol this has this is not a budgeting
issue at
all yeah this is that you love um
someone who's an
alcoholic yeah and it sucks because he
doesn't see it that way so it seems like
I'm the nagging wife right and here's um
what you've got to
do um unfortunately there is no healing
in your marriage there's no healing in
your financial life there's no healing
in underneath your marriage and
underneath your financial all that all
that leads to this moment where you
don't feel safe in your own house do
you no no none of that changes until he
chooses to get
clean and so no matter what the issue is
when somebody comes in and says hey I'm
struggling with X and Y and Z and I'm
drinking and I can't quit doing XY
substance nothing happens on the mental
health side the marriage side the
emotional until somebody says I'm gonna
I'm willing to go get clean and what
that means is you have to take care of
you because you're not safe and I I
don't even doubt that this guy loves you
but this guy's got some significant
struggles that he at this time is
unwilling to deal with and so you have
to make your safety priority number one
what does that mean it probably means
you need to find somewhere for him or
for you to go for 30 days and say hey
I'm not going to live with somebody
who's unsafe anymore I'm tired of being
on eggshells in my own house I'm tired
of not knowing where all our money goes
I'm tired of not knowing where you go
and then you come home on Monday and
kind of make it my fault like I thought
we had all this he's got to decide to do
something different and that means going
to a meeting starting tomorrow morning
even though tomorrow's Thanksgiving see
what I'm saying like this is a this is a
way bigger deal than budgets
yeah and can I just be honest with
you yeah you know this
right yeah I mean he doesn't get upset
about it he just says like like what's
going on like we sit down and then I'm
like well this is what happens and then
he's like oh you know what yeah you're
right I'm going to work on it so listen
behavior is a
language and what he's telling you is I
don't care what you and I agreed on I
don't care what you and I um I don't
care about our our marriage
Fidelity I don't care about our
agreements I don't care about our
Financial Health I care about going on
Friday and Saturday nights and doing
whatever the crap I want to do
period I don't care how you feel in my
own house I don't care if you feel like
I'm a liar I don't care if you can't
trust me I get to go party on Friday
Saturday and
Sunday yeah well he doesn't go party but
he Jinks that home but okay well he's
he's going to disappear on his own house
on Friday Saturday Sunday yeah yeah
Behavior's a language and he's talking
to you loud and
clear so this this is the point when you
go get a friend you go get a pastor you
go get a therapist and you sit down and
come up with some really Ironclad
boundaries that are going to be brutal
for you to
enact it's going to break your
heart yeah and that might be there is no
alcohol in my home anymore period
if you if you lie to me and commit
Financial infidelity again then I'm out
I'm going to go move in with my
sister you have to go to AA like your
boundaries have to be pretty tough at
this point is that
fair
yeah I can hear it on you you're worth
more than than what what the the life
you're living right
now
yeah Jade am I crazy no you're not crazy
I I hate this for you it's tough and you
know people all the time they call in
and they're talking about issues that
aren't they're not money issues and here
we're always telling people like combine
your money combine your money but there
are times where it's like there are
situations there like no don't combine
your money like you said you seek
counsel and I tell people all the the
time like there's This Acronym I use
about keeping your money safe and it's
like if you're in these situations like
you know our friend calling in here
Laura where you're concerned that the
first thing is you need to seek counsel
like that's the S you got to seek
counsel and the a is if there's abuse
and if there's addiction that's when you
got to do it or the F Financial
infidelity that that's what we're
looking at and then they're going to
give you the E which is you can evaluate
your options based on the boundaries you
have because I'd like to say it's it's
as easy as all right move out tomorrow
but it's not it's it's never that easy
and there's always awake you know what
I'm saying always and so I would just
encourage anybody who's in that
situation like I said abuse addiction
Financial infidelity yeah you're not
like you said you're not safe in your
own home and that person cannot have
continued access to the things that make
you safe right in your family that keeps
your kids safe because if you have
somebody who's spending all the money on
substance and your kid can't have
groceries and your kid can't eat and you
can't get to work because there's no
money for gas yeah you got to put some
boundaries in place and you have to say
like you said that in my home there
there will be none of this and until
this happens you will not have access
and that's probably the toughest line
that you can lay down but that's loving
yourself well and honestly that's loving
them well right and it's loving this
thing that we decided to create together
which is called a marriage that's right
that's right oh it's so tough I hate
that she's going through that I hate
that it's happening you know during a
time like this the holidays where you're
supposed to be able to come together
with the ones you love sometimes you
have to create that distance that
separation and create that boundary so
that ultimately things can get better
and you can find Healing create your
free every dollar budget today the
simplest way to budget for your life